hey jennifer hey steve how are you
great honor to be here so jennifer uh
we met a long time ago
and
i thought maybe we'd start by you uh
maybe telling everybody
how high were we when we met
and some of you are going what what kind
of question is that
do you remember how high we were
we were 11 000 feet
we were at 11 000 feet here make sure
you note that to your parents okay
where were we and when was it
i actually don't remember the year but
it was in yosemite back country
high sierra camps it was we were we were
hiking across the the high sierra camps
and i just would like everybody in our
audience to know jennifer was the first
person
ever to see drawn in the sand the
beginnings of the lean startup when i
was trying to explain it to anybody who
would pass by including these random
people i didn't know i was drawing it in
the dirt with a stick
and in fact it was you and
your husband who in fact renamed it from
market development to customer
development so we've known each other
for a while but you've had a really
interesting career
you know you were a teacher for seven
years right and then you came back to
stanford and got your mama in
teacher and curriculum development
and then you went off and and joined the
seed fund for for education what was
that connection how how does a m.a end
up as a venture capitalist then well so
so on that with just a note on on where
we met in yosemite i'm pretty certain
that i wouldn't be doing this job today
if we hadn't literally crossed paths
you're in the back country of yosemite
and you you were on your mules
you and he had his two daughters with
them and they were like you guys
literally were on mules
and we were hiking in the back country
because people have called me an ass
before so
it was very appropriate and it was my my
first kind of real exposure to the
concepts of customer development and
entrepreneurship so it really sparked
something in me um in that experience
but to your question about how i how i
ended up here yeah a lot of people ask
how does a teacher end up running a
venture philanthropy fund
and i i had taught for seven years loved
teaching but felt i had plateaued and
really wasn't
meeting the needs of my students
very well i was teaching u.s history and
then my last year i actually taught
taught teachers differentiated
instruction and for what age group
middle school and high school okay
so i
felt like i had plateaued a bit decided
to go to grad school came to stanford
got my masters in curriculum and teacher
development and i started hanging out
hanging out a little bit at the business
school and i saw kim smith speak and she
was the founder of new school's venture
fund and she talked about this idea of
hybrid teams bringing educators together
with um mbas and entrepreneur
entrepreneurial people and and people
that had more of a business and
technical background and i was really
taken with her vision of
there's a place for me in this this
world of entrepreneurship so begged her
for a job um she hired me on as a
part-time research assistant
and i worked there for um i've been
there this is my ninth year actually and
so after my
so really kind of learned how to do this
job um by
um
shadowing you know
basically like apprenticeship shadowing
the partners at the time i had great
mentors
and then three years uh three years ago
my friend and i wei we actually launched
this seed fund
to formalize the structure of edtech
investing at new schools so so let's
back up you you've raised some really
interesting questions one is
this idea of kim smith had
what nine ten years ago or even even
further that was something unique i mean
what what was the unique insight and
what were people doing before and
what changed after uh new school's
venture sure so um she had this
so she founded new schools with brook
byers venture capitalist and um john
doerr another venture capitalist and
they came together and they thought can
we bring the venture model into
education and can we
bring the kind of rigor and discipline
of investing in early stage
entrepreneurs and support them
but the the difference between our model
and a traditional venture fund is that
we prioritize impact so we are um we're
looking for sustainable scalable strong
businesses companies but we are
above all else prioritizing um impact so
that was the first difference so what
does impact mean are you doing charter
schools or software or yes teacher
training um
we we have this belief that there is
sort of no silver bullet for education
so the answer is not charters or edtech
or teacher development that it's really
a complex system that requires
um
entrepreneurial energy in all across all
these different sectors
so we we do invest
grant money to non-profit charter
schools we have close to 400 charter
schools in our portfolio wow
yeah and we invest in um
teacher training programs and then i
focus on education technology investing
through the seed fund so really good so
the the idea that fun
covers all these
ways to change education and what you're
focusing on is
tech is that
edtech exactly so and so what's an
edtech so we started investing in edtech
so new schools was founded 16 years ago
and we started our first investment was
actually great schools which is still
around great a really great company and
we have always invested in edtech
but we started about three four years
ago we started seeing some some kind of
differences out there in the funding
environment there was a lot more angel
investing and our schools were absorbing
technology like never before
so we we thought the time is right let's
um formalize this this fund now we moved
our headquarter two or our office to
palo alto
um and we started
started investing in in seed stage
attack and i think edtech is like a
catch-all for um
you know this intersection of education
and technology companies and it can be
companies that are focused on students
that are focused on teachers uh most of
our investing actually is is targeted at
teachers
and you said though that one of the
goals of new schools was impact is that
still true for the edtech investing
you make yeah absolutely impact or is it
profit or is it these 501 nonprofits
yeah so we have
so we're agnostic if it's non-profit or
for-profit okay so new schools will say
what is the best way to get at the
impact goals wait a minute you're a
venture fund that would fund a
non-profit i've sat on boards where i've
decided they were non-profits but that
was by accident not on purpose
so you actually fund them on purpose we
have some of those in our portfolio
but at least you could say oh we meant
you guys to be a non-profit no no we
actually have some for-profits that are
that are not that are closer to
nonprofits but you can make that
decision on day one as a fund that these
are something that's worth funding yeah
yeah and i think that's what's unique
about this space is that we have amazing
non-profits in this space khan academy
ck12 read works that are
strong scalable sustainable
nonprofits but we have them side by side
you know top-tier venture-backed ed tech
companies that we co-invest with
wow so we are you know again it goes
back to this idea that there is like no
one single solution it's a it's a
complex system that requires like you
know we need hardware in the schools but
we also need software that teachers can
use and the students can use and these
things work together
um and we kind of see that's what i
think is really unique about new schools
is that we see this whole system we
touch all different parts of it and we
we can see where the needs are so
our
fund is really need driven thesis driven
so we ask our teachers we ask our school
leaders you know what's preventing you
from
what's preventing your students from
reaching high levels of student
achievement and then they will tell us
this is what we need we need a better
way for teachers to share lesson plans
we need a better way for students for
teachers to be trained on the spot and
we will go out looking for those
solutions so
before we go through some of those
solutions which i want to hear about you
said something earlier that i thought
was really interesting is that the
adoption of new technologies has
accelerated in the last couple of years
and in schools is that is that true
absolutely and
what is what's driving that or is it is
it legislation is it ipads is it
something is it it's now time or the
students have more tech than the schools
have i mean
yeah there's there's quite a few factors
i think one is that i would say this
edtech revolution has been led by the
teachers
and they are the ones adopting these
solutions bringing them into their
classrooms and using them that's a big
idea why do you think that is well 40
of us
teachers um there's four million u.s
teachers um are under the age of 30.
so they're young they've grown up with
with technology
and this is the way you know they're
banking online they're shopping online
they come to school and they get you
know in most schools this is what you
get your file cabinet your textbook and
your you know your paper grader
and they're saying you know no way we
want
technology tools that are that are as
good as our consumer technology tools so
that's a big change right so teacher
driven because they're the outside world
for them is computerized and they're
going back into something that looks
like the little house on the prairie
school house
is that yeah and what else any any
impact of legislation or or
no child left behind or is that all
orthogonal to what's driving no it's not
it's you know what actually this is
so three years ago we started this fund
what was really a driver of the change
was um the budget cuts actually
and the the severity of the budget cuts
and they were faced with do i you know
you know one of our schools that we
funded kip la uh do we not open the
school or do we open it with more
technology and a greater student-teacher
ratio
um so that was that was you know that's
been one driver of getting of getting
the technology into the schools
um
and then there there's a lot more
devices right like there's nine million
ipads in us k-12 schools
we have 2 000 schools are one-to-one now
and we expect that number to be close to
100 percent of schools to be one-to-one
which what does that mean sorry i fall
into the education lingo um one device
per child oh really i mean they assign
somebody an ipad yeah so when you when
you register with school you get your
textbook you get your ipad you get your
and who pays for those devices it varies
so
um
sometimes the schools pay sometimes the
parents pay
um some of the funding for this is being
covered by um title one funding for for
low-income schools
that's that wow that's really
interesting and and has the
entrepreneurs changed in the 16 years or
are they the same their motivations or
their technology or their
goals or are they the same
that you've seen yeah thankfully they've
changed a lot so
you know i think that that technology
used to come to
come into schools um
innovation came you know with a car in a
car you know so the sales person would
drive up and have some cd-roms and show
the it specialist
you know there's oregon trailers or
whatever the software was
and the it specialist would um purchase
that that technology with often without
talking to teachers and without having
any data on the efficacy of this product
and then they would roll it out to
the teachers kind of you know top down
force teachers to use it
and that that's the way technology was
was what came to our schools in the 90s
but now thankfully um the way it's
happening is that that these teachers
are adopting the technology into their
classroom they're using it they're
understanding how it works with their
students they're getting
efficacy data doing kind of mini
research in their own classrooms and
then they will kind of pitch their
school leader to purchase the software
license wow
that's a real shift it's huge it's like
the difference between pcs entering the
corporation versus mainframes being
controlled by a single department and a
cio yeah same ideas like consumerization
of
of i.t right like
that's a great insight and and but have
the entrepreneurs themselves changed i
mean do they all have the same vision
that they had in the 90s or are they
more savvy less savvy same problems
different problems
um
so yeah you saw two of them up there
i'm biased of course but i think i think
they're amazing like these these
entrepreneurs are we have more
entrepreneurs coming from
um
engineering and from um the consumer
tech sector coming into education so the
first guy that you mean women you don't
stop them at the door and send them away
so if there's some sort of engineering
students and some tech
entrepreneurs you'll let them actually
go we welcome them with open arms we
love them in education love them
so um the the krishna he has students
now he has students he has children that
are in school and he wanted his kids to
to be able to to learn coding computer
science early on so that's why he had
built um tinker but he had two
successful companies in consumer attack
prior and he then decided to go into
edtech because he had kids yeah
is that sometimes a motivation for
absolutely yeah and roughly across our
portfolio we have
46 ed tech companies in our portfolio
and 45 of them have been founded by
teachers interesting so tell me about
the portfolio and tell me about the
types of deals you see and in fact let
me ask the canonical question how many
deals do you look at or get pitched or
get get thrown over the transom a week
yes
i think we're really lucky because new
schools has been around for 16 years and
has a has a name and presence in the
space
so we get 20 to 30 companies coming in
our pipeline per week a week that's
about a thousand to 1500 a year yeah do
you read them all
um no
i used to so what's the first give me
the characteristic for anybody watching
or hear what is kind of a good first
order pass for an edtech deal to be
looked at
for you and new schools so like the
space or both the space and the
entrepreneur and then how do they then
we'll ask you know what's your email
address so they can email you personally
but it doesn't work
it is open it's out there but but first
of all the space what are you currently
looking at how do you kind of sort
through
these thousand to 1500 as a as a venture
capitalist but a venture capitalist in a
very specialized niche yeah what should
people be watching or listening think
about when they're thinking about
pitching a deal sure so we focus on k-12
first so education market covers kind of
pre-k through higher ed we we focus on
on k-12
um and then we were thesis driven so
we've identified some of these problems
which i mentioned earlier
um what are they again yes so these are
these are problems mostly identified by
our schools that we are investing around
but but i also want to say that we are
not dogmatic about following our um
investment areas because
i'm continually surprised by our the
entrepreneurs that come through our
doors and show us what they are doing
with technology and that is um you know
so we're open to breakthrough
innovations that entrepreneurs bring us
but what are the thesis okay so the
thesis are um i think first is that we
we focus on underserved populations so
we are looking at companies that are
going to
service special education students
english language learning students first
generation college going students
so these are areas that have been
terribly underserved in the past so the
tools that teachers have
in these areas which are heavily
compliance driven are just terrible so
we are looking for innovation in those
in those sectors give us some examples
okay so
first our first investment out of the
seed fund was a company called gold book
and this this guy is amazing daniel you
and he was a oracle um
coder developer and then he became a
special education teacher in ravenswood
so he had this really unique mix of
engineer and teacher and so he had coded
up a solution for teachers to create
individualized education plan goals for
their students so in special if you are
a special education child you have these
iep goals um and they're which means
what which are goals that um the
teachers and the parents and all the the
people that are supporting that child
are working towards so you're on the
same page you automated the process
exactly so he automated that process but
he also brought great research into it
so he infused this um
this research coming out of boston into
the goal making so that's an example one
one thesis special education research
community next thesis so another thesis
is tools to help teachers differentiate
learning what does that mean that sounds
like an education phrase yeah so um
so differentiation is actually the
number one topic of professional
development requested by teachers and
has been since the early 90s
so um
basically the idea is that our school
system is one size fits all that we are
in a mass production school system we
kind of batch kids through through our
school system which worked really well
when we were preparing kids for
factories during the industrial age but
now we have demands of a very high high
skilled economy and that does not work
anymore
so the idea is we're moving closer to
personalized learning and
differentiation is a set of strategies
that a teacher would use to help
personalize
instruction for children so instead of
breaking them in separate classes it's
how does one teacher actually
personalize the content for
uh
so exactly
so just give you a real quick example on
that one there's a company we funded
called newsela
and they bring current events into the
classroom so they have partnerships with
like new york times and washington post
and they bring great journalism into the
classroom but they level it five
different lexile reading levels for
students you lost me they do so um they
leveled the the the article so you
there's an article
from new york they kind of rank the
complexity of the article exactly so
there
there's actually a standard lexile it's
called okay and you can
you can
level any text for different reading
abilities
so the idea is that all students in the
class can engage in the same article
whereas before you know they would split
kids up and then you'd have you know
names like this is the bluebird group
and they're reading like really
interesting text and then you have the
you know buzzards that are reading you
know cspot run because they're
struggling readers and it's very
stigmatizing to kids
and the idea now is that you can engage
in the same article and then they can
have a discussion around so that's
another thesis yeah yeah so that's a
differentiating instruction
then we're really focused on stem
science technology engineering and math
so we're trying to build this the stem
pipeline for k-12 yeah and example
tinker was one of them at coding we have
three coding companies in our portfolio
tinker code hs
and uh codenow which is a non-profit got
another thesis or is that um so then we
have
underserved
stem we do a lot of digital oh big data
big data is a
actually really important one so this is
basically tools that extract data from
students learn student learning and
provide a really nice visual dashboard
for teachers or decision makers
that are making decisions about a
child's placement or
even like what they're going to learn
tomorrow
and
we have a four or five companies network
so this is decision management for
examples and teachers exactly be more
effective about utilization of teaching
resources and yeah okay got it and so
were those kind of the general so how
many companies a year do you fund
so we fund um 12
12 to 14
so companies let's see let me do the
math that's about a hundred to one
yeah right so for every 100
plans you see you find one yeah all
right so i see somebody in the back
writing up a hundred plans right now
right so
you you
and and what's the filter how do you
kind of decide i mean
how do they get is it personal
introductions or what's the best way
for your fund to connect to an
entrepreneur so so there is
there's easy ways to reach anyone at new
schools you can we do have my email is
on linkedin and and available and and
people do email us directly i get
at least one or two per day um
um we have funded one one we okay one of
them so what's the more effective way
other than spam yourself really awesome
company bright bites
mit
guys um so you never knew them before it
was a cold email it was just cold email
so one out of a couple hundred all right
but but what's the other way that they
should get all of your fun so usually
they come in through warm introduction
through
um
so entrepreneurs are great pipeline of
referrals of companies so they should be
spamming your portfolio right
right for an intro is that what you're
suggesting is that they should be
meeting the scenes
yes
yes and so but that's just a natural way
that venture capitalists tend to feel
yeah i mean it's not that that different
i guess that right
if someone vouches for someone that says
this is an interesting company or this
is a great entrepreneur
yeah you listen up yeah exactly i mean
we really do try to be
open because we believe that you know
especially in education some of these
great ideas are coming from
teachers that are toiling away in their
classrooms and building solutions
and they may not be connected to anyone
in silicon valley so we want to find
them too right so so the standard model
for certainly here at stanford and if
somebody's you know watching online or
listening to podcast is you know
everything needs to be a billion dollar
company is is that the goal of these
tech companies if do they need to come
in and prove to you that they're going
to get 20 million students in year one
and then yeah is there a different model
for what actually yeah i um
no they don't so because we prioritize
impact we're not looking for so say that
part again because we prioritize impact
big deal so you're not looking for the
little graph that looks exponential like
facebook though you wouldn't throw them
out right right because there's some
you know there's a reason why that that
data is going up into the right and so
we want to understand why
but
i actually looked this up um just today
that there's been 11
ed tech companies since uh it was 1998
that are considered like ed tech
unicorns billion dollar
valuations but that's bob but that's not
what your small number yeah and and so
what do you look for when they talk
about you know scale and business or
whatever so besides a great idea and you
think it's interesting what are the
other things you're kind of filtering
out yeah i think that you know this is
one of the things that we have gotten
we make a lot of mistakes too i should
say that like we i don't
feel like i have you know um
some magic you know see into the future
that all these companies are going to be
successful are you sure you're a venture
capitalist
mean we are coming in at the earliest
stages when they're these ideas are raw
like many times they're just a feature
they're an idea because it's a seed fund
yeah because it's we're at the top of
the funnel it's it's a seed fund
so um
we're doing a lot so i think like the
most important thing that we're looking
for is
um
authenticity so is this person
authentically driven to solve a problem
and that authenticity could look lots of
different
ways right like it could be a teacher
that was like daniel that was um you
know faced a problem in his classroom
and so he built a solution for it we
have a great company called no red ink
this this um this teacher in chicago
actually chicago he was at chicago
public high school and he was tired of
grading papers and so he found a
developer on on craigslist and he
actually created this the solution no
red ink so you know he was very
authentic like here's a guy that's just
like driven to solve a problem
so we are looking for
the what is driving them to to start
this company is it authentic and then
we're looking for courage too like
starting a company as you know steve
intimately that it's it takes a lot of
courage or stupidity one of the two
right
you're looking for the courage side of
that spectrum
i never would have gotten funded
and so so courage authenticity um and
then impact on the specific field yeah
kind of aligned to one of those one of
those themes and do you give them some
examples is there stuff on your website
they should look at or
uh we have a link to steveblank.com
i was thinking about is your list of
your portfolio companies up there yeah
yeah and and so what mistakes the the
people you fund in that tech not just
the ones to get into you but the ones
that actually are funded do you see some
common mistakes of entrepreneurship yeah
we do um
it's this is an interesting one because
i think it's two sides of the same coin
we see
we see companies that don't think of
themselves as as technology companies
so they think of themselves as an
education company they have a lot of
great former teachers that are starting
this company
um but then i say you know where's your
where's your tech team where's your
developers and they say oh you know we
we uh outsourced that to wherever and we
built our product and now we're gonna
sell it
and
you know that that is sort of a red flag
to us because that that harkens back to
the technology of edtech of the 90s
where they'd you know build this product
and then they just blow up this huge
sales force and just go sell it to
schools and then
what's wrong with that well the product
wouldn't have
literally like would go you know 10
years and not be changed
and not be improved
and they could they can't respond to
user needs they they can't they're not
getting out of the building and and
talking to their
their um
their teachers so you want to see a
whole team uh both someone see a hybrid
team of of educators and technologists
right what other mistakes do you see in
tech yeah so on the flip side of that is
sometimes we see heavy technology teams
that don't have any educators in the um
in the the leadership team
and i see you know those are those are
problematic too because
i think it is really beneficial to have
somebody that understands schools and
education deeply to
to be helping guide the company
um and then i'd say like maybe one other
big
big mistake
companies make is that they
because there's so many teachers
adopting these products and they are the
ones that are really driving the
attraction that they build this product
for the teacher but then forget that the
payer is the administrator and that
there's a whole different set of
processes and
and needs that that administrators have
so
so that's interesting so you mean they
kind of confused that there might be a
multi-sided market and dealing with
users and payers
yeah right and and that they might
actually know that the users are
passionate but there
might as well be a non-profit because
the payers don't care is that
yeah i would characterize it like that
yeah they um
there's there's a lot of companies that
have figured this out and have done a
really amazing job of of
capitalizing on this like user base
right and actually
um using these teachers to kind of
upsell to principals and administrators
i think wiki spaces has done a really
good thing but is your point that that
should be a strategy not a
not an accident yes yeah yeah exactly
interesting
and and of without naming names are
there some spectacular failures that you
now kind of think back to and i don't
you know no if everybody likes to bury
their dead believe them that but then
you wish you knew you know what you now
know about i i should have seen these
happen and that are kind of education
specific yeah there's there's definitely
i've got some of those in in our um
in our portfolio but um
there's a there's one that i think that
really frustrates me that i we invest in
this company because this is one of
those as i mentioned like you learn this
job by doing you learn it by making
mistakes and you learn it by
by seeing lots of companies and by by
actually doing the work
and this one company that we invested in
this is early on
um
they the cap table i i sort of didn't
look at closely enough cap table the
capitalization table that basically says
who owns the company okay how the shares
are divided and what i didn't realize is
that the the
the founder um his share of the company
was actually like super small and he'd
come out of this incubator this
accelerator that owned most of the
equity of the company so he he basically
felt like you know hired help to run
this company
and it played out that way
so so what would you do different now or
what do you do different
i i look very closely at the cap table
i try to understand who all those people
are and cousins and uncles on the on the
cap table and and then i
um i think it goes back to like data
like like pattern recognition you get
better at
looking for that authenticity in so you
want the founder engaged and yeah this
has got to be his he's he or she he's
they're going to create this company
with or without us no matter what they
feel strong conviction for this company
so that's what it's one of the most
important things that we look for good
and and any other lessons that were
expensive or interesting
um
they're ongoing so many
you know yeah i think there's another
one that i learned that is
um
that i sort of projected my vision for a
company onto this company
and i was so excited about this vision
and it was really like when i think
about it was my vision it was not
this founder's vision
and so we just sort of
had there was a lot of friction there
interesting direction the company should
go and and
let me just kind of close this with
trying to understand the context of your
fund in the funding ecosystem you're a
seed fund right and that implies what
and for additional funding where do you
fit and what happens in a successful
path yeah so we're we're very active ed
tech seed fund so we were the number one
um most active ed tech
funder the last two years so what does
seed mean so first generally it means
first money in sometimes it's after an
accelerator an incubator
so we are um pre-series a investor and
is that like five thousand dollars or
five hundred thousand dollars so our um
ticket size is usually like one fifty to
two hundred thousand ticket size is that
yeah speak for something is that
investment investment is how much um 150
to 200 000 right so that is a seed round
enough to get you started and what do
you expect them to do with that money we
co-invest with with other angels
actually so how much is that
so this is interesting so when we first
started the seed fund average seed
rounds were about 750 okay in edtech and
now they're about 1.5 million and what
do you expect a startup to do with a one
and a half million dollar seed ramp
so our companies we we bucket them into
three categories and one is you're going
to get to sustainability on your seed
round alone
so goal book is a company um that that
achieved um
profitability on sustainability means
make more money than you're spending
yeah okay yeah that's bucket one um
second bucket would be you're you're a
good candidate for foundation or
other type of impact financing for
follow-on
so you're not vc
profile but you there may be impact
investors like um
yeah
dell foundation got it there's a lot of
angel investors that are interested in
in impact yeah and then the thing the
third is you're you're getting ready for
vc round financing and uh vcs are
actually interested in the space
yeah very very much so so
uh last year there was
452 million invested in in k12 ed tech
in one company uh
across across a number of different
companies but yeah there's like um
bessemer is in
klein or perkins we've co-invested with
excel is in two of our companies um so
yeah there's quite a few great and and
so they go then down the traditional
venture pack yes how interesting yeah
and and so what would you tell uh
entrepreneurs who were interested in
edtech
today what should they do when you know
or why should anybody be interested in
edtech those who
haven't even given much thought about
about this area
yeah i think that um
this is such um
this is such an important
um sector such an important area as all
of us you know sitting here at stanford
know
um that we have our education system is
is really
is really suffering right now especially
for
the
low-income
students
so in our in our country that if you if
your parents did not graduate from
high school then the chances are that
you will get to get to college and get
through college or about five percent
and in other industrialized countries
that's 23 percent
so education which used to be this
amazing escalator of opportunity
for for people in the united states is
especially
um those in lower income people it's not
it's not the case anymore
and um yeah there's lots of stats that i
can i can tell you around that but it's
it you know i think it's it's ripe for
innovation and the time is now to be to
be building at tech companies so is is
is the way to think about this is the if
there's more to life than 140 characters
you should be thinking about giving back
and in tech i mean there's nothing wrong
with social media but this actually
affects people's lives a little
differently than than
other things you could be doing with
your time
and by the way you mentioned u.s is that
where your funding is is the focus on
just u.s tech companies you know we're
being drawn more and more outside the us
but we've invested in two
canadian companies
and we
are across the portfolio about 15
percent of users that are using the
companies the products are um outside of
the us will you look at deals outside
yes definitely oh interesting yeah and
so you seem to be like committed to this
is that yeah and and why
personally yeah um i mean you now have
enough you know
like points in the game to kind of go to
any venture fund
why are you doing this one
you know i think it if i would sort of
play armchair psychologists with myself
and think why am i drawn to this space
i think it goes back to um
i grew up in outside of chicago
and i grew up in a suburb glen ellen and
it was a western suburb and very middle
class community
and my sophomore year we moved into the
city and i went to chicago public high
school
and it was just it was
you know just vastly different
experience in the quality of education
better work
a lot worse a lot worse
so
long-term subs just um the teachers
were not high quality
um
just the opportunity that was offered to
the kids is not the same
so
we moved back the the following year
into the suburbs but i consider that
year like a real gift in my life and in
understanding that opportunity
um
is so important for for people and and
schools our education institutions are
incredibly important to make that
opportunity happen
so i you know i think human potential is
everywhere it's not just in palo alto
and silicon valley
and we need to make sure that we have
schools that can really tap into
people's potential so it sounds like
you're on a
mission you could say that so is there
anything i should have asked you
what questions did you wish i would have
asked
no we could maybe open it up too we will
but no no no you're blushing already so
there must be a question
you're either happy i didn't ask
or you wish i did
um i don't know i think
i think maybe the
the this path may sound like it's been
oh easy i kind of you know was a teacher
and then i popped in to see kim smith
and then i went to new schools and now
i'm investing in education and but it's
been you know it's been um it's been a
steep and long learning curve for me and
when i came into new schools i was a
researcher and i didn't have an mba now
surrounded by these harvard and stanford
mbas who
would talk about leverage and value
proposition and level five leadership
and all of this fancy
mba talk and i was so intimidated they
didn't know what it meant either
but now i
now you use those words
i'll drop leverage a couple times a day
now
a couple more times this talk
so um
so i think that you know i was and i did
feel when i first started at new schools
i was my ninth year like very
intimidated by by that
and i guess like
if i could give you know as you guys
don't need advice but if
if i could offer something that i took
away from this experience is that
to value what you bring to the table and
value your skills and what your
experience and what you have done
because i feel i feel like i undervalued
my education experience
um i has i was the the only teacher at
new schools at the time that you know
had taught more than two years that was
a non-tfa teacher
and i didn't i feel like i didn't didn't
i didn't value that enough in myself it
turns out you were the only one who
actually knew anything that built it so
so i think that's a that is a great way
to kind of end the conversation but um
i want to thank you for your for your
time and uh i learned a lot and so thank
you jennifer
so um do you want to take some some
questions for the audience
so uh questions yeah do we have a mic or
uh we're gonna just do this if you can
repeat the question
um in working in the field how have you
seen companies looking towards making
their product have a large impact
because psychology is so expensive have
there been any innovative ways that they
look towards getting this across a wide
breadth of people in schools that don't
have the private school or charter
school funding that yeah can you repeat
that okay the question was how can you
grow your
company um inexpensively right is that
right
well so now things have changed and
there's great ways there's distribution
channels into schools so we have the app
store which teachers use
on the ipads there's nine million ipads
in our schools we have um
the uh
google chromebooks the google play for
education store there's edmodo
app store so i think that that is a good
first sort of first line of getting your
app out there and
um seeing you know getting your feedback
and and growing from there i mean i'm
amazed actually that some of these
companies they put their app up there
and they grow like class dojo this is a
fantastic company
hus dojo um spent zero dollars in
marketing and grew to you know 45
million students just through the app
store
um
yeah and having like a they have a blog
and they have some social media presence
but mainly through without these things
people the other thing is that teachers
word of mouth teachers love to tell each
other about great products and they will
and so there's there's a natural
virality in
in education
thank you
right there do you find any mental
health or emotional health companies
related to students
uh the question is is social emotional
learning or social emotional health
emotional health social muscle learning
yeah we're looking into that more and
more actually we're doing diligence on a
company right now in that space
so i think it's
it's um
it's really important and we know that
those
those qualities are are you know
predictive of of student success in lots
of different ways
so yeah there's there's more and more
companies out there in the space
okay
next
um how do you justify to your clients
investing in non-profits and also can
you give us some examples of ways to
measure your impact
sure so the question is how do we
justify non-profits
investment in nonprofits
yeah it's a good question so we
um have invested or granted money i
should say out of this seed fund to six
non-profits
and uh because we do not prov we do not
return we do not provide returns back to
our
limited partners
so
the money that comes into us to invest
is philanthropic capital it's donations
so so you use the profits to kind of
ever green the fund right exactly
reinvest in more companies exactly so
we've had several exits some recently
engrade we had this year wireless
generation carnegie learning
um
blunt space and profits from those
returns are recycled back into the fund
which we then happily invest in
other entrepreneurs
but you had a second second question oh
how do we measure impact um lots of
different ways so we care about we
collect metrics from our companies every
quarter and we care about retention
retention is very important for us
our our teachers using these products
we measure net promoter scores of the
products
we look at student achievement gains
when we can
next question yeah i just have a
curiosity i just wanna do you ever take
input from different education models
from different countries
around the world
um
yeah so the question question is do we
look at other education models um in
other parts of the world and take that
into account when we're thinking about
our investments
no in general
so yeah i was in
china two years ago visiting the schools
in chengdu so we do
we do look we should do more of it but
we do look at other models and we
certainly look at the international
rankings of of schools
student achievement across the countries
okay
other questions
how come this side of the room hasn't
asked anything
you guys are like all in detention in
school or
there we go all right this is kind of
close to that side test
um
what sort of things would you like to
see assuming you had like any power in
congress in terms of education reform
based on your own experience yeah that's
a good question
what was the question the question
is if we had um
endless bank account to to change
education or to to reform education what
would we do
i think i would want to move us away
from this system that is based on
essentially seat time so you kind of
move through the system
grade by grade
and move it to a mastery-based system
so that it's based on your mastering
different concepts and you're moving
more fluidly through the system
um i think it's this this system that we
have right now based on on sea time is
very constraining to schools does
anybody run that experiment
yeah there are schools that are um doing
mastery-based learning where you can
spend variable time in in the school
well you spend you kind of work through
a set of objectives at your own pace
right so if you like
finish it fast you're out and if you're
not that fast you're still there
yeah i'm not sure what happens when you
finish all of the
the objectives if you're actually out
but
there's schools in alaska i know they're
doing a lot of work in that front and
um
there's there's lots of schools around
here too that are more tech enabled
i think that's a big one um and just the
way that teachers are trained and the
way that teachers are like i was
i went to the the school of education
and if you go into that coverly library
you see that all of these like
research journals hundreds of research
journals which essentially hold all the
secrets to how we best teach kids and
that those are inaccessible to to
teachers that are in the classrooms
teaching students it's just ridiculous
in this day and age of technology that
that teachers are not given access to
the latest research on how best to teach
students
sounds like a startup in there yes right
we'll fund that if on that one right
there anybody else yes right here um so
so i was just curious what exactly are
your firm's specific goals um because
you talked about um mastery education i
was curious um what else would you like
to see um what what end goals do you
want to see achieved in the student
united states education system
yeah so so there's
the goals are the oh so he was asking
the what what are our firm's goals what
are new schools goals
um our mission is to transform public
education through passionate ideas
powerful ideas and passionate
entrepreneurs
for the most underserved kids
and so we are
we're we are really focused on this
achievement gap which has gotten worse
and worse over time so since the
1960s there has been um the gap between
affluent and poor students has grown by
40 40 points
and now it is double that of the
achievement gap between black and white
um so
you know say that last part again so
class is now important more important
than race absolutely u.s educational
yeah
yes and the research has been done by
you all ought to like think about that
for a second that's a big piece of data
and it's the research has been done by
professor at stanford sean riordan
and yeah it is more of that class is
more important than race in in
educational success predictor of
educational success is which also is a
predictor of income yes
what is scary is that now 48
of of students in our nation's public
schools are eligible for free and
reduced lunch
so almost half of our kids
and this majority in some areas of the
south are
eligible for free and reduced lunch
which is a proxy for low income
well
yeah
race and class are not necessarily
mutually exclusive so that's right one
can define another one so
does that piece of information tell you
yeah i mean it's
you can see that so the the there's a
great piece in the new york times about
this actually that um that it that talks
about has a bunch of graphs uh was race
and income are not mutually exclusive
yes but they're not um
completely overlapping either right
that's that's the surprise
other other questions
ah on that side you get to ask two
because you're representing the entire
side of that auditorium
yeah just building what you mentioned
about goals would you be supportive of
goals that um you know such as like
online education replacing physicality
in schools altogether would you be
supportive or would you endorse those
goals like you know i complete my entire
high school requirements online or my
university requirements online yeah save
on so much money building physical
schools and maintaining them would you
be supportive of this school yeah it's a
good question so the question is would
we be supportive of
um virtual 100 yeah 100 online education
virtual schools
so it's an area that we're looking into
quite a bit now because it's the fastest
growing subpopulation of schools
in the us now and it's growing 11 the
best research that i have
tapped into is 11
it grew last year and and
it's growing almost
twice as fast as charter schools
so um it is a very important
a
very important sector to think about we
have not made many investments in that
any investments actually in that space
we have made space investments in
blended learning models that are still
focused on teachers being the
coordinator of learning in the classroom
but
you know there there are a lot of
just to be honest here there's a lot of
bad providers in that virtual learning
space k12.com um is one of them it's a
billion dollar company
and we would love to see some disruption
of
the
the um
the dominant players in that space and
why are they not optimal
um their results are bad their their
results around helping students learn
when you look at student achievement
results are
why are they dominant
i think that there's they're they're the
market leader and there's
so few alternatives right now and kids
are opting out of the traditional school
system and are going totally online
so it sounds like you're asking for some
business plans in this area yeah yeah
yeah that is that that would be looked
at kindly if people were
pitching you those ideas it's a hard
space to get into because
you have to create a very comprehensive
product it's not like
um some of the other products that you
can kind of wedge into with the
with a little product a little mvp like
you actually really need a comprehensive
soup nuts
product that you're providing and that's
difficult to create that's yeah it's
hard
so we have time for one or two best
questions okay
all the way back nope that's you
so
no no no no no don't defer to the guy
he's a good friend yes back up people
interrupted you
unless you're related
we've worked together before then smack
them twice
after you make the investment in the
company what does your relationship with
them look like how long do they remain
in the portfolio how do you continue to
support the founders center yeah this is
a good question the question is once
they're in the once we make the
investment how do we support these
companies so
we do we we believe that we have a
hands-on
role with these companies after we've
invested in them and so we um they're
seed companies so they don't necessarily
have a board most of them don't have a
board
i am on on seven boards though of
companies that have now you know grown
up and have raised their series a and
and um invited me to the board
so we
we actually we have a set of supports
that we provide actually our director of
portfolio supports is here she's she's
in the vac eva
and we we have some kind of scalable
support so we have great strategic
partnerships with google and apple and
edmodo
that we're able to support our companies
through
there's a lot of
kind of
inter-portfolio convenings that we do we
bring our portfolio together they share
best practices with each other
we do a lot of
you know i'm constantly texting and
talking with our companies on different
problems that they're having so
we we support them in
very kind of traditional ways that a
seed fund would but i think that we
bring an education lens and we have a
great network um in the education space
and we have almost 400 schools that we
that we are close to and i've seen this
it's an amazing uh uh amazing
interaction support yeah we have it at
st who has a quick best question okay
quick best question right there
so in the last few years there's been a
lot of
um
concern about the costs of technology in
terms of shortened attention spans and
distractibility there's actually an
interesting
quick
what's the question not the lecture
what's the question
in the new york times that what's the
question
seriously we're running out of time
what's the question what is what's your
opinion on the downside of technology
right uh
particularly in light of like
all
all uh school children being issued
okay so
um
question was like what are the downsides
of tech so um
we have focused our investing on schools
institutions and really focused on
teachers so we haven't had i don't mean
to dodge a question but we haven't
really had to deal with um the early the
very earliest ages you know zero through
five of children using technology and
there's there's definitely
um there's more and more research out
there there's there's recommendations
from the american pediatric association
about screen time and things like that
um but you know i have three kids my own
and i can tell you that this is really
hard like we
vacillate between you know giving our
kids ipads so we can get something done
to um you know to like like banning
technology for for you know months on
end i think it's i think i think
we really got to get better at figuring
out what is the balance of the
technology in the classroom so jennifer
thank you very much